[Music]
for 17 years she's been in our lives
without growing up peppa pig is the
preschool phenomenon that has captured
the hearts of millions of children
across the globe holly williams is in
london this morning with the inside
story of one of the world's most loved
characters
good morning there are plenty of british
icons from buckingham palace to the
beatles but you may be surprised to
discover that one of the united
kingdom's most influential cultural
exports is bright pink and attends
nursery school
[Music]
needs no introduction the queen
hello to you all hello queen
if not then welcome to her very quaint
very english world
the queen loves jumping up and down in
muddy puddles
she started out small 17 years ago on
british tv
but pep has now transformed into a
global phenomenon
watched in 180 countries and 40
languages
the cartoon was recently sold in a 4
billion deal to u.s toy giant hasbro
pepper's family motorhome we do spend
time watching peppa pig peppa is so
famous that hillary clinton gushed about
her on a british chat show when she met
one of the series voice actors this is
going to be huge for me
she has her own theme park in britain
with another one scheduled to open in
florida next year and a third planned in
china
and some american parents have even
complained that peppa is giving their
children british accents
how clever it doesn't matter i can
easily find a new best friend
they call it the pepper effect
she's a very english pig
and a lot of the story lines are quite
english why does that translate around
the world
we're talking about very human emotions
and feelings so the dynamics are
resonates with internationally with you
know any family because we all love our
children
its story lines are simpler than many
other children's cartoons but a single
episode can take months to craft
we actually kind of create a flow of
logic that is very easy to follow for a
four-year-old there's no nasty conflict
and there are no really evil characters
nothing's ever allowed to get to a point
of real conflict
which is part of the simplicity of the
storytelling making sure that we're not
over complicating the stories really so
we can stay that pure and in the moment
and also some of peppa's anthropomorphic
friends are voiced by illustrious
british actors
i mean shouts fog
brian blessed is an acclaimed
shakespearean performer with a famously
loud voice
who plays grampy rabbit
a fitness-obsessed senior citizen
it's a very joyful happy world do you
think that's important to the success of
peppa pig it does
embrace happiness
it has many levels
but it brings joy it makes people happy
but even peppa pig has experienced
controversy one episode was pulled off
screens in australia where poisonous
spiders abound bye bye mr skinny legs
some say daddy pig has been fat shamed
in the series and claimed the cartoon
reinforces gender stereotypes but the
show's current makers say from the very
beginning the four-year-old pig has been
ahead of her time she was a female role
model which was actually very rare at
the time it was very much speaking to
kids on their wavelength at that time in
a way that other shows weren't hey how
you doing i'm miss rabbit
peppa's latest episode see her family
take a vacation in america
a road trip from coast to coast
new york the city that never sleeps it's
a much busier screen than you normally
see with peppa
i can see a bakery lady with an ice
cream that's the statue of liberty she
doesn't know what that is yeah
absolutely you think it's a lady with an
ice cream
and they're eating ice cream so it's
perfect you know it's a perfect
opportunity
it's an eccentric love letter
sent from britain across the pond are we
in hollywood yet daddy pig and
everything you'd expect from a badly
drawn cartoon pig who's won a global
following by embracing happiness
for cbs saturday morning holly williams
london
i never knew about peppa
after your kids time yeah but you knew
you knew yeah and now she's changing the
accents for the kids it's so that's
really unlikely and yeah and your pig
was pretty good you want to give us
another one
how about yours
there you go
wow